while i was traveling in new england i
found myself
surrounded by people
i haven't been surrounded by people for
a very long time and it felt
weird very weird not least because
there's a pandemic and there's a virus
and it just was like
is this okay luckily we were following
all the state and local guidelines
being smart and i found myself going
through this really weird mind process
first being scared that i was around
people and then being like oh but i'm
wearing a mask and so it's probably fine
i'm wearing a mask masks protect me but
then being like but do masks actually
work
didn't the cdc and who come out and say
like
don't buy masks masks aren't the most
important thing here it was really
annoying that they then reversed their
position anyway it got me just thinking
what does a mask actually do
and is it actually protecting me when i
am around other people
and i did what i always do and this sort
of thing comes up and i went on
a deep dive we put surgical masks on and
i want to explain to you
four major takeaways i've had about
masks
by the way this really cool green mask
that i'm wearing and a bunch of other
ones that
you'll see me wearing in this video come
from my friends over at bioskin
who make really nice comfortable masks
that
are breathable and wonderful and i'm
going to talk about them later for now
let's talk about the science of masks
takeaway number one your breath is kind
of like
a rocket ship ignition
bear with me on this one i promise it
will make sense watch this guy
sneeze it's kind of gross but
this process is like a rocket ship for a
virus
who wants to escape the orbit of your
body
make it out into space and land in the
orbit of somebody else's body
through this rocket ship these
respiratory droplets
sometimes that stuff lands on surfaces
like a doorknob
and you touch that surface and that's
how it makes it into your world
hence the mantra we've heard a million
times
but as we got into this virus more and
more scientists started to study
how the virus actually moves around and
they started to say with a
loud megaphone as loudly as they could
the virus doesn't just spread through
droplets it also spreads through
aerosols and all of us are like
what the hell are aerosols and the
scientists are like aerosols
are just like the rocket ship but
they're actually more like that little
capsule that always breaks off the
rocket ship when all of the fuel parts
of the rocket ship
fall back down to earth this little
capsule keeps flying
out into space it's way smaller and
it's just floating not subject to
gravity okay so back to this guy
he's not even sneezing now he's just
talking
or breathing and all of this is the
aerocells that are emitting out of him
propelled in a specific direction it
turns out that
even after the droplets fall to the
ground and onto surfaces
the virus can stay in their little hatch
these little aerocells
and can float around never falling to
the ground
this is really important in
understanding masks and i will explain
why in a minute but first we have to
unpack
a second big takeaway i've learned while
looking into masks which is that number
two
the less virus you get the less sick you
get
this is what i think actually most
people get wrong
about the virus and it's actually
something that i did not understand
until i
delved into the science here still
trying to noodle over what the
implications of these findings are for
for masks and which type of masks one
needs
i had always thought that if you catch
the virus you're gonna get sick
and how sick you get depends on how good
your immune system is
turns out that's not the case covet 19
the disease and
all viruses and their effects are not
binary it's not that you just
get them or you don't get them you can
get really bad symptoms sometimes deadly
and then you can have really mild
symptoms and you can even have it
with zero symptoms at all and one major
thing that determines
how bad those symptoms are is your viral
load how much of the virus
gets into your body if a really small
amount gets in
it's likely that your symptoms will be
very very low
the more virus you get exposed to the
worse your sickness is
this isn't actually a new concept this
is something they've known since the 30s
i guess i didn't know it and so i always
figured it's
an on or off switch you either get it or
you don't and that's just not the case
so yeah it's a pretty simple thing to
understand i mean
you could go sit through the hour and a
half lecture that i did from
university of california or you could
even dive into the studies
that they did where they put literal
masks on hamsters
or you could just take it from me the
less virus you get
the less sick you get okay so we have
these two pieces of the puzzle
number one the virus can break away from
the droplets and turn into aerosols and
float through the air and
get into your body and number two the
more virus you get
the sicker you get okay let's put those
two together
to figure out what masks actually do
so number three what masks actually do
once you put on your mask something
happens to
everything coming out of your mouth
let's go back to our space analogy for a
second
putting on your mask is like increasing
the gravitational
force of your proverbial planet
imagine how hard it would be for a
rocket ship to escape earth's gravity
and get into space
if the gravity were five or ten times
more intense so what a mask actually
does is it
just increases the gravity of your
proverbial planet makes it a lot harder
for something to launch from you into
the world lots of those droplets get
caught in the mask so that stops them
from even escaping in the first place
but the ones that do escape and the
aerosols that escape from them
have way less momentum they slow down
the trajectory they create
different currents and eddies that keep
them in your sphere
so if you're infected and the virus gets
out of your body in one of these air
cells
it's much less likely to spread to the
people around you
it's just like you have a bunch more
gravity
you can see this with this aerosol
photography technique
the person with the mask is talking just
like the person without
their aerocells are still escaping but
they get slowed down and they stay
within the orbit of the speaker as
opposed to
getting sprayed out into the world masks
help
direct the particles and aerosols that
make it out of your breath when you are
talking
or coughing or sneezing okay so does
this mean that you should only wear a
mask
if you are sick and you have virus to
project out into the world
which is sort of what they told us at
first let's be honest no it turns out
there's
science now that shows us what masks do
to people who are not infected
let's talk about that second piece of
the puzzle that i discovered which is
the more virus you get
the sicker you get inevitably some virus
from a droplet or an aerosol will make
it out of someone's mask even if they
have a really good mask on
some will come out let's say you're
nearby when that happens
if you are wearing a mask there's no way
that your mask is going to filter out
all of those aerocells and all of those
particles those particles are too small
they'll slip through your mask but if
you are wearing a mask
inevitably some of those particles will
get
blocked leading to less virus getting
into your body which can actually mean
way less severe symptoms which could in
some cases mean
saving a life even if it's just 50
that gets blocked that could have a
major effect on how sick you get
in addition masks protect me from myself
i tend to touch my face like a lot of
humans do just
subconsciously when you're wearing a
mask you don't actually have
access to the vital parts of your face
that could let virus in
so if you're touching doorknobs or other
surfaces that are communal
you suddenly have a blockade from
yourself which leads me to my last and
most important point which is that the
math
of masks is insane you really better
wear a mask
so quick recap masks make
the proverbial gravity around your
proverbial planet
more intense so that it's much harder
for things to escape your orbit
and for the wearer who is not infected
it helps
stop some particles from getting into
your system leading to a smaller viral
dose
leading to less symptoms so imagine if
all of these forces come together
you're in a public space and everyone is
wearing a mask
everyone is getting the gravitational
effect they're getting
the filtering effect they're getting the
don't touch my face effect
all for themselves and for each other
when this happens
something magical occurs ateespatia and
minutephysics did a collaboration on
this to unpack
the probability math that occurs when
everyone wears a mask
masks are also complicated because they
fly in the face of our mathematical
intuition
what they show is that there's this
multiplier effect that when everyone is
wearing a mask
the probabilities of transmission go
down dramatically
more than you would ever expect this
helps me understand a major question i
had while i've been in the covit 19 data
mainly when i was working
on the new york times piece i was
looking at all this data especially in
asia
a lot of these countries who are used to
wearing masks like taiwan
or china or vietnam had really low
death rates even if they had high cases
and that's because
a lot of people wore masks and so people
who did transmit the virus in these
crowded places
got less dose of it and became less sick
and fewer people died because of it
wearing masks
truly does save lives and here in the
united states if we had taken this
seriously
and really had solid leadership on
wearing masks
a hundred percent we probably could have
saved
a lot of lives so masks are here to stay
for the
foreseeable future which is sort of
waking me up to the fact that i need
a comfortable effective mask i don't
really have one i sort of use these like
homemade masks
don't really do the trick for long-term
use which is why i'm excited
to be partnering with my friends at
bioskin this is a company from my
hometown i actually grew up working at
this place
they're a company who has focused on
materials and fabrics
and creating technical and breathable
fabrics for sports bracing
and they've helped innovate in that
space and they've created a mask
that is breathable and incredibly
comfortable
and comes in loads of different designs
they've run studies on this
to find fabric that is breathable but
also effective in filtering and i got to
tell you i'm very happy with the design
the breathability i find myself being
able to wear it for
long amounts of time and not feeling
like i want to take it off which is sort
of a dangerous thing when you want to
take off your mask
so they're safe and they're snug and
they're durable
they're machine washable they have a
little metal thing on the nose
which helps keep a really tight seal
around the nose
very important and they come in these
awesome
three packs that are affordable and
durable bioskin is offering a 10
discount to my audience if you go to
bioskin.com
johnny harris and enter the promo code
johnny harris you'll get 10
off i 100 recommend these
um i know this company really well i've
known them for years
and i can vouch for the quality of this
product
so thank you bioskin for supporting this
channel
thank you all for watching and wear your
mask
oh and ps they also have kids masks too
which is really cool so i have kids and
okay bye
you